Cries for help from an Iranian s
player spared execution
for now as his country's brutal
sentence other protesters to dea
In the span of just six weeks.
Amir Nassir as a Donny one from
two sentenced.
He was accused back in November
of being involved
in the killing of three security
This was in the wake of Mass Age
Amin, his death
at the hands of the morality pol
one way or another, as the Irani
tried to round up protesters
CNN's Don Riddell reports for us
Now, supporters of Azadi says
he was forced into confession, p
a sham joke trial and is being t
behind bars right now.
Amir Nazarov
suddenly has been living the dre
as a professional football playe
But within the last few weeks,
his situation has turned into a
After protests
swept through the country in Sep
Iranian state
media accused Nasrallah's attorn
of being a member of an armed gr
that was charged in the killing
security officers in November.
The government says that he conf
to participating in the crimes
and now faces 26 years in prison
Nasrallah Madani denies
that he's guilty and his support
that he made a false confession
and was tortured in jail.
In an exclusive voice
message obtained by CNN, with th
of the activist group members ac
he can be heard appealing for he
from within the prison walls.
Before I started to volunteer he
I don't feel safe.
Would go to a session that says
you is an online petition urging
shouting it as if you're not a w
only the best of the survivor
Kong which has such a beard on u
He's been in jail since December
where his family is worried for
as the government has already be
executing protesters
Last Saturday,
the Islamic Republic executed
two more young men,
including the karate champion Mo
Mehdi Karami, bringing the total
of executed protesters to four.
That's
according to the UN's human righ
Karami took up karate at the age
and went on to win medals
at Iran's national championships
But during anti-government prote
he was accused of killing a secu
officer and following a rushed t
supposedly based on a false conf
He was found guilty and executed
just a month later.
The human rights organization
Amnesty International says
that his trial was a sham.
His fate echoes that of the Iran
wrestler Navid Afkari, who was j
for participating in protests
and then executed in 2020.
His defiance inspired other athl
to speak out as well, including
karate champion Mahdi Jafar Gala
who fled the country in 2008.
I've got plenty of messages from
1718 years old kids
that they did when they just see
killing and torturing on the str
and all that kind of stuff.
They just
they just telling me, okay, you
because they know me
because of my background etc.
and they just say, yeah, I like
It's, it's done for me.
Like I'm going to kill myself.
Athletes in Iran seemed to be ba
a new fight against what activis
are calling an unjust judicial s
and then making a plea
hoping the international communi
will pay attention.
If I don't get it.
When I was on my way
and when I got pushed by a stran
of what's wrong with the
a member of almost Mousavi emoti
this as you it might get dirty.
At this point, the recording cut
I mean, Nasrallah's attorney say
he will have much more to say
when he gets out of prison.
But for now,
he needs others to be his voice.
Otherwise he could be silenced f
You know, I asked Murray Jafar G
who he featured
just then what athletes in other
who are watching this can do.
He said simply that they should
what's going on to make sure
as many people as possible know
what's happening right now insid
CNN has reached out
to the Iranian government for co
about both Amir Nasr as a Danny'
and also the fate of Mohammad Ma
Karami Jake, we have not yet
received a response back to you.